اقبال الكبير على مراكز الاختراع في
الانتخابات الثلاثيه البرلمانيه والجهويه
والبلديه يؤشر الاحتمال تسجيل نسبه مشاركه
مرتفعه ورغم حده المنافسه خصوصا في
العاصمه وكبريات مدن البلاد فقط طبع
الهدوء واجواء المراكز الانتخابيه
الاقبال كثيف وعلى للمكاتب مسلسل فيها قدر
من الخلق وفم سير العمليه الانتخابيه مما
يسعى ان عندنا تخوف اعلن العمليه
الانتخابيه الذي قد ما يكتمل كل مكتب ما
يكمل عدد
عدد الناخبين نحن نقول الامور كامله
الجهات المعنيه
وتدخل وتدخل اللجنه بنفس الوقت وتدخل جهه
اي ملاحظه
لجنه جاهزه
لجميع المشاكل
يتنافسوا في الانتخابات الجاريه 25 حزبا
على مقاعد البرلمان البالغه 176 تعتمد
النسبيه لانتخاب نصفها وثلاثه عشر مجلسا
جهويا ونحو 240 بلديه
تكتسي الانتخابات الحاليه اهميه خاصه فهي
تنظم على مشارف انتخابات رئاسيه مقرره
للعام القادم يرجح ان يترشح فيها الرئيس
الحالي لعهده ثانيه وهو ما يفسر حده معركه
تعزيز المواقع بين اطراف العمليات
السياسيه ابراهيم مصطفى العربيه نواكشوط
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات